when both dactyl acclaimus pythiformis
and dactyl Acclaim as hystras were
discovered the ability to study them at
the genetic level wasn't available yet
but this is a different era and James
took the slide with the cover slip on
top and floated it in water letting him
carefully remove the cover slip without
killing the precious organism inside
then he needed to clean the dactyl
acclaimus so he used a pipette to grab
the organism and move it over to a clean
drop of water and then again to another
drop and then one more to one last drop
before storing it in a tiny tube in his
freezer from there this Frozen
dactylaclamus will have part of its DNA
sequenced revealing the genes that make
it the way it is and maybe even
uncovering some of its closest microbial
relations